government affairs uh
um
marcy
marcia fudge who's represented the
district as well
and mitch lander who's leading the
implementation of infrastructure mitch
they don't know anybody from new orleans
down here used to be the mayor of new
orleans and i called him mayors know how
to get things done as the mayor tell you
here and i called him asking he be the
hands-on guy to actually implement the
law
implement it get it done and let people
know how they can access it and uh
and brenda brendan malloy chair of our
council of economic quality brenda where
are you
there you are thank you brenda we rode
up together on aircraft together and
it's great to have you as well i also
asked
to say hello from someone who you know
in lorraine but
couldn't be here today yeah a tremendous
fighter and uh
ohio for ohio workers and a guy who
could easily be standing where i'm
standing right now sherrod brown
yeah
sharon down working in the senate
keeping an eye on those other teams that
other team see what's going on
it's good to see it congresswoman
chantel brown where are you chantelle i
said there you go right in front there
congratulations and it's great to great
to have you here
and uh and of course marcy marcy captain
marcy has not only made history as the
longest serving woman in the history of
the house of representatives
every day she's making a difference she
never ever slows up
and she's helping this region compete
and thrive and come back
you know
that's what i want to talk a little
about today
excuse me
the historic investment we're going to
make to restore the great lakes lakes
strengthen the region's economy provide
clean drinking water clean up our
communities and create good paying jobs
a year ago
when i spoke at a joint session of the
congress i was coming off the podium
platform and marcy came up to me and
with all the press in the gallery
looking down handed me a note a letter
and the commentators reporters were so
damn curious what did she hand you
what's in that note
and i said i can't tell you no i
but uh
well if you know marcy you know what
that letter was about
the great lakes
the great lakes she described the
treasure
the treasure the great lakes are they
connect eight states two nations
to provide more drinking water than any
set of lakes in the world and more than
40 million people
benefit from that they support more than
a one million three hundred thousand
jobs in manufacturing tourism
transportation
warehousing farming and fishing
and they're essential to shipping goods
made in the midwest all across the
country and around the world
generations of families have depended on
them being voting on the boating fishing
and hunting and swimming that they
provide for everyone in this region
those who come and visit there are homes
that countless natural and cultural
wonders that
should be conserved for all to enjoy
today tomorrow for generations to come
and marcy by the way i started tonight
she said i got another letter for you i
don't know what the hell you got
marcie i promise you i'm working like
hell i
but i'll i'll read it i promise whatever
you say i'll do but uh
marcy's letter said this is why i want
by bringing up
she said and i quote
the great lakes
undergrad life
work and recreation for millions of
people
and we need them we need to invest in
them we want a brighter more prosperous
future for the region
well
they are
they are and we are going to we're
investing like never ever in history
back in 1987 an independent commission
identified 43 places called areas of
concern along the great lakes
there are areas where pollution as
as uh epa directors said were pollution
from industry runoff from agriculture
poor wastewater treatment put the great
lakes and everyone who depends on them
at risk
26 of these areas
are in the united states side of the
border 12 of them are in canada
and five are shared between the united
states and canada
and our mutual nations made a commitment
to clean them up to be good partners to
protect these shared treasures
and for decades there was a lot of talk
a lot of plans but very little progress
it was slow
that changes today
today we're announcing an investment of
one billion dollars
one billion dollars
from the bipartisan infrastructure bill
it's going to allow most significant
restoration of the great lakes in the
history of the great lakes
we're going to accelerate cleanup of
sites across six states in the great
lake basin from duluth minnesota to
milwaukee wisconsin gary indiana buffalo
new york and everywhere in between
we know these sites were dangerously
polluted for decades we're committed to
clean them up three decades ago we made
this commitment
and yes we've gotten a couple of them
done like right here like the one
my old hangouts as well i went to
syracuse university and i was a
lifeguard on on lake oswego i uh and i
uh and i know the oswego river up in new
york that was another one that's been
taken care of
now we're talking about cleaning up the
cayuga river behind the cayuga gorge dam
and in the process and that passes
through cleveland
the uh
the the the i always mispronounce it the
mawami river right
guami
river in toledo i can say toledo
[Applause]
restoring
the shoreline around the detroit river
in michigan the saint louis river
minnesota and wisconsin the grand
calumet river in indiana and so much
more
dredging polluted sediment restoring
wetlands and habitats making the water
safer for swimming fishing drinking
providing habitats for wildlife and
wildfire
and the study found that every dollar we
spent cleaning up the great lakes
generates between three and four dollars
in economic benefit that's a fact
and it's a really good investment
these are not only investments in making
or making the great lakes last month we
announced over 500 million dollars
upgrade to soo locks in michigan which
connect lake superior and the great
lakes
7 000 vessels and 90 of our country's
iron ore moves through these locks every
single year
that ore makes nearly all the
high-strength steel that goes into
us-made cars and appliances
replacing and modernizing the locks will
not only create good jobs doing that
it's going to strengthen our supply
chains and get goods moving faster and
reduce costs
this is not the totality of what we're
going to do
but it's an example of what i've said
from day one we're rebuilding america
we're going to invest in america and
build a better america than we found
and for the better part of the 20th
century we used to lead the world by
significant margin because we invested
in ourselves we invest in our
infrastructure our roads our highways
bridges ports airports the arteries of
the nation that allow commerce to
function smoothly and move swiftly
and we invested in our people and in
opportunity we're among the first
nations to provide universal high school
at the turn of the 20th century we
invested to win the space race that
facilitates
that
in facilities like lewis research center
in cleveland which is now named for my
buddy john glenn god rest his soul and
we led the world in research and
development and led the creation of the
internet
and but somewhere along the way
we took our eye off the ball
we took our eye off the ball our
infrastructure used to be rated at
number one in the world
today according to the world economic
forum we rank number 13 in the world
china and the rest of the world is
catching up and passing us
but now with our infrastructure law
we're reinvesting in our economy in our
and in our people
reclaiming our leadership and creating
millions of jobs for building a better
america that's what we're going to do
but as we rebuild america
we're buying america and betting on
american workers
this buy america law makes the most
significant investment in roads and
bridges and highways nearly 70 years
through the through the infrastructure
law
fixing as many as 1 300 bridges and
nearly 5 000 miles of highway right here
in ohio that are in poor condition if i
know parenthetically i was not long ago
i went to visit a place in pittsburgh
pennsylvania
where a bridge that was well over 100
feet off the ground going over a gorge
completely collapsed at 6 30 in the
morning
thank god it was only three vehicles on
it no one died
but had it been during rush hour kids in
school buses there would have been
numerous people that were being killed
or maimed
american workers building these roads
and bridges with american-made steel is
how we're going to do it
jobs making the high-speed internet
affordable and available to the 14 of
households in the state of ohio that
don't have the internet
we also know that ohio has the second
most lead pipes in the country we have
650 000 lead pipes here in the state of
ohio
we're going to start
undoing the legacy of lead which has
poisoned too many of the region's
children
that means replacing 100 of lead water
pipes and service lines and addressing
what they call pfas the dangers for
every chemical
that are a threat to the drinking water
here in ohio and other parts of america
every american every child should be
able to turn on a faucet
and know that the water they're drinking
is clean and safe
we're also going to create thousands of
good paying jobs in the process with
union plumbers and pipefitters for
generations
the industries that built and defined
america steel
cars tires paint all of them grew and
thrived right here in ohio
right here in the banks the banks of the
black river workers built and launched
900 vessels
freighters tugboats tankers mine
sweepers cruisers built right here
were part of our arsenal democracy in
world war ii
making it in america is what this region
was built on making it in america
this region built america it's not
hyperbole i'm not just saying that
because i'm here it's a fact
the midwest built america
and we're building it again
[Applause]
again you've heard me say this often
you know
if
wall street's a good there's a lot of
good people in wall street they do good
things a lot of them not all but a lot
of them
and guess what
the fact that mad wall street didn't
build america
ordinary middle-class people america
and manufacturing and unions built the
middle class
so
we're bringing manufacturing jobs back
taking supply chains back home from
abroad so we have a better jobs and
lower prices and and now instead of
losing manufacturing jobs since i came
to office with the help of the
congressional delegation down here we
have added
375 000
manufacturing jobs in one year
[Applause]
in 2021 we saw the highest increase in
um
and you in
union manufacturing jobs in nearly 30
years
a couple of weeks ago the ceo of intel
joined me and senator brown and senator
portman and by the way
i
grew up in a senate that really was
bipartisan senator portman played an
important role in this legislation
and so at the white house we they came
to see me and the head of the or the
intel came
they wanted to announce he wanted to
announce at the white house
20 million dollar investment 20 billion
dollar investment
in semiconductor campus outside of
columbus ohio
now semiconductors are badly needed
those computer chips to manufacture
automobiles appliances cell phones and
so much more
we invented them but we don't make them
anymore and relative to the rest of the
world it's going to create 10
000 jobs
10 000 jobs
by the way
seven thousand jobs constructing this
massive facility
and three thousand jobs running the
facility making an average salary at
that facility of a hundred and
thirty-five thousand dollars a year
blue-collar work
pretty good money
manufacturing essential products that
are stamped made in america
and there's more
just a couple weeks ago general motors
announced a 7 billion investment in
michigan to manufacture electric
vehicles
creating 4
000 new quality jobs
that's on top of the announcement that i
say for that was general motors and ford
made last year an 11 billion dollar
investment in electric vehicles creating
11 000 new jobs
three weeks ago in western pennsylvania
after i went to look at that bridge
the union pacific railroad announced the
largest purchase of american-made
battery electric locomotives in history
in history
and because the infrastructure law also
delivers
7 billion 7.5 billion dollars to build a
national network of 500 000 electric
vehicle charging stations all across
america along our new highways and i
might add built by the i
installed by the iebw
last week a company called tritium
announced a new manufacturing facility
in lebanon tennessee to build 30 000
electric vehicle charging stations per
year
using american iron and american steel
and american workers
creating 500 new permanent jobs in
tennessee
we're seeing the drum beat of good
paying jobs unlike anything we've seen
in our history
but not only that these announcements
we're also showing that growing the
economy and creating jobs can go hand in
hand with protecting the environment
not decimating it meeting the moment on
climate change
like our program to clean up abandoned
mines and cap and plug orphan oil and
gas well sweeping and spewing methane
into the air
thousands of those wells and mines are
right here
in the ohio river valley
here in the ohio get and they're going
to get paid the same amount capping them
as it costs to dig them and create those
and they're again good union jobs as
good as these jobs are folks digging
those wells are proud what they're about
to do because now they're going to cap
them
the infrastructure also helps us invest
in cleaner stronger more resilient
electric grid
with 100
clean electric energy being generated by
the year 2035.
and some of those utility poles and
transformers are going to be installed
by machines that are right here at a
place like skylift
you know all of this is doing going to
do is create more good-paying jobs and
make more make us more globally
competitive and help us fight climate
change and get to net zero
to get to look
there's so much more to say i'm inclined
to go on but i've kept you too long let
me close with this
if you've done what you've done here in
lorraine shows what's possible
you've reclaimed your waterfront
cleaned your drinking water
restored wetlands which will help
protect against storms and flooding from
extreme weather and the spring thaw
and set the stage for jobs and
businesses of the future
you know
tomorrow
would have been the birthday of lorraine
one of lorraine's most famous daughters
tony morrison
nobel prize winner pulitzer prize winner
[Applause]
and i might add my wife who's an english
teacher and professor in college
uh the first lady's absolute one of her
favorite authors i remember her going
over to princeton to interview tony
morrison for a paper she was doing for
one of her doctors
her doctor not one she has a couple
masters one doctor
tony morrison is also the mother-in-law
of the chair of my economic
council my economic advisor council of
economic advisors dr cecilia rouse
tony passed away a couple years ago
the reason i mention her is not because
of her relationships to the
administration
but her words that she told us to live
by she once wrote quote we got more
yesterdays than anybody
we need some kind of tomorrow
we need some kind of tomorrow
places like the rain have a lot of proud
yesterdays
now they're going to have some brighter
tomorrows
and because of all of you
well god bless you all may god protect
our troops and the reason they tell me
i've got to head out i hadn't planned on
going immediately is because of weather
going back to washington
and there's a little thing going on in
europe right now so uh
so may god bless you all as i said may
god protect our troops thank you thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]